I now introduce Gibbs sampling, another
randomized algorithm for motif finding.
Gibbs sampling works somewhat
similarly to the randomize motif search.
The biggest difference is that randomized
motif search is a rather reckless
algorithm.
It can actually change all found motifs
that
at every iteration depending on what are the
profile most probable k-mers.
It allows to move
very quickly in
the space of the solutions
but there is a danger that you already
came close to the correct motif,
and then jump away from this motif, because
randomized motif search
moves so rapidly through the space of all
possible motif.
Gibbs Sampler is more cautious.
It actually changes only one
of the chosen motifs at every step.
This slide shows the key difference between
Randomized Motif Search and Gibbs
Sampling.
Instead of showing you the pseudocode for
Gibbs Sampler,
let me show you first how it works.
Let's first randomly select motifs shown
in bold in this slide.
In the set of Dna strings, as before,
blue elements shows implanted motifs, and
bold
elements showed motifs that
we randomly selected.
After we've done it, let's do something
strange.
Let's actually remove one of the found
motifs
along with the sequence it belongs to.
In our example, we remove the third motif,
and remove the third Dna sequence from
consideration.
We'll consider
the resulting set of just four motifs, and
build the Count matrix based on this set.
And then afterwards, construct Profile
matrix based on this Count matrix.
And after we constructed the Profile
matrix, we will calculate the probability
of all k-mers in the deleted string.
Afterwards, we will do the following,
again relying heavily on rolling the die.
There are seven probabilites we computed
and we will roll a seven-sided die
according to the probabilities we computed.
It will be heavily loaded die
with probabilities of sides proportional to
the probabilities that we computed.
After we toss this die, we choose a new
starting
position of the Motif and proceed in this
way.
This is new a substituted position in the
deleted sequence.
So that's how it works and then of course,
it iterates until motifs keep improving,
or until a certain number of
iterations (let's say 100,000 iterations).
So, here is the outline of Gibbs Sampler. We
randomly select a
k-mer in each sequence, as before.
We randomly choose one of the selected k-mers
from sequence
called Sequence* and remove it from the set
of motifs.
We create profile from the remaining
motifs.
For each k-mer at the position i in
Sequence, we compute its
probability of being generated by profile,
resulting in n-k+1 probabilities.
Afterwards. we generate a die with
n-k+1 sides
whose probabilities of sides are
proportional to probabilities we computed.
We roll this die and,
depending on the outcome
of the die, we turn back this motif
number i to the sequence that we removed.  And
we reiterate.
So let's once again look at how Gibbs
Sampler work.
Let's assume that we've done the first
stages and we're
about to generate the, probabilities of
every k-mer in the sequence.
I am still considering the same example I
considered before.
We generated
our seven probabilities, but now let's pay
attention of what these
probabilities are. And it turned out that
six out of seven probabilities.
I actually zeroes.
Should we roll a one-sided die?
Four centuries ago, Oliver Cromwell warned us
against rolling
one-sided dice.
He told in his famous appeal to the court
of Scotland.
trying to convince them that their
alliance with the king was an error.
He said: "I beseech you, in the bowels of
Christ, think it possible that you may be
mistaken."
Cromwell Rule in statistics implies that the
use of probabilities
0 and 1 should be avoided,
unless we talk about purely logical
statements.
Thus, we should actually give a
little probability even to extremely
unlikely event.
For example, we should give small
probability to
the fact that the sun won't rise,
tomorrow.